-Today is Veterans Day, and we
wanted to do something special
to honor all those
who have served our country.
So we have
an announcement to make.
We here at "The Tonight Show"
have chosen to donate
to one of our favorite
veterans' charities,
the Fisher House Foundation,
in the amount of $150,000.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
The Fisher House --
If you don't know,
the Fisher House
provides housing
for families
of military and veterans
while their loved one
is receiving treatment.
It's a great organization.
We're so proud
to give back to them.
But there's one more thing
we wanted to mention.
Our friends at
the Home Depot Foundation
started a brand-new contest this
year called "Operation Surprise"
where people
all across the country
get to nominate
a U.S. military veteran in need.
And the winner gets $25,000 to
go toward critical home repairs.
It's a great thing. And I'm
happy to say that the winner
of this year's "Operation
Surprise" contest
is here with us tonight.
They're sitting in our audience,
and they have no idea
that they have been chosen.
♪♪
-Ooh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Oh!
[ People speaking indistinctly ]
♪♪
-Is Vernita here?
Is Vernita Love here?
[ Audience "aww"s ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Can you stand up?
You can stand up, too.
Vernita?
Vernita Love?
[ Laughing ]
Vernita, I'm so happy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is going to get good.
This is only going
to get better.
Vernita --
-My eyelashes --
-[ Laughs ] It's alright.
-I got to make sure
my eyelashes --
-Your eyelashes are still on.
Yeah, your eyelashes --
Can we make sure her eyelashes
are still on?
Vernita, is this your son Aaron?
-Yes.
-Aaron is the one
who nominated you.
[ Audience "aww"s ]
Aaron, can you tell me
a little bit about --
Tell me a little bit
about your mom.
-Yeah, my mother, man. She's --
[ Laughter ]
Single mother from the East Side
of Detroit, Michigan, man.
She's raised me by herself.
She served 26 years
in the Air Force.
[ Cheers and applause ]
She's --
She's -- She's retired.
But at the same time, man,
I don't know anybody
more selfless than her.
I mean, she'll give her last
to make somebody else good.
I mean, she gives
to the homeless vets in our area
and is always constantly trying
to do things in the community.
I entered her in the contest
because her house is home,
but behind the scenes, man,
it's a wreck, man.
The electrical on it is old.
[ Laughter ]
-It's not that bad.
It's a beautiful place.
-But I try to help out.
But, I mean, this $25,000
would definitely help out
in a long way.
-As the winner,
you will be receiving $25,000
for repairs for your home.
And we actually have
one more surprise for you.
Although $25,000 would really
help, after hearing your story,
the Home Depot Foundation
is doubling the prize
in partnership with the --
You'll be receiving $50,000.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Get those eyelashes off!
-Did they fall out?
-No, no.
Here, please, have a seat.
I don't want you falling down.
I love you.
Have a seat right there.
Enjoy yourself.
Aaron, here. Take care -- Yeah,
and make sure those eyelashes
don't fall out.
[ Laughter ]
Congratulations to you.
Thank you to
the Home Depot Foundation.
Aaron, you're a good son.
-Thank you.
-Thank you, buddy.
Thank you to
the Home Depot Foundation.
And thank you for your service.
I'm so happy. Stick around.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.